eyes up opposers this can't wait this
morning Roseann posted a racist tweet
about former Obama advisor Valerie
Jarrett and hours later ABC canceled the
highly rated reboot of her sitcom I knew
the Liberals wouldn't let a trump
positive show on the air
what changed ABC because Roseanne has
been writing racist tweets for forever
or at least since 2013 maybe this new
one was just her workshopping season 2
episode ideas like how she accused her
Muslim neighbors of being terrorists
that's just fun family television
honestly what's going to happen to our
favorite Roseanne characters like Rose
and the husband guy all the
Becky's I'll tell you what they're not
going anywhere because sorry ABC but the
First Amendment grants everyone in
America the right to a sitcom and sure
it doesn't have to be on ABC maybe we'll
go do whatever the white nationalist
version of Roku is or Netflix because
Roseanne was just doing what she
promised she'd do
show us Trump's America